[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Please
welcome to the stage the Death
Wish Coffee Company.
[APPLAUSE]
This is the welcome crew.
So there are a lot
of you up here,
and I know you guys all have
very unique and complicated
roles inside the company.
So it'd probably be best-- why
don't you guys just go down
the line?
Introduce yourselves, and
let people know what you do.
MIKE BROWN: My
name's Mike Brown.
I'm the owner, founder,
CEO, and chief janitor
at Death Wish Coffee.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: My
name is Dustin Alexander.
I do shipping.
I do inventory, and
I do purchasing.
I'm also part of the
podcast with Jeff.
TEAH TERIELE: I'm Teah Teriele.
I'm the marketing
manager at Death Wish.
KANE GROGAN: I'm Kane Grogan,
and I run our customer service
department, some
of our event stuff,
and sales, wholesale,
stuff like that.
JEFF AYERS: I'm Jeff Ayers.
I run our brand new
broadcasting division,
and I write and edit and produce
our weekly podcast, "Fueled
by Death Cast."
ALYSSA HARDY: My
name is Alyssa Hardy,
and I'm the content
manager for Death Wish.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So the reason
why we brought Death
Wish here today--
and I think it's relevant
to a lot of Googlers--
is there's this great sort of
just Homecoming King-esque type
story of starting out
in a basement and just
the explosion of
the past five years
that your company
has gone through.
Why don't you recap the history
of the company for us, Mike?
MIKE BROWN: Yeah.
So back in 2008, I opened
Saratoga Coffee Traders,
and it was a small coffee shop
in Saratoga Springs, New York.
And I learned pretty
quickly that I
didn't know how to run
a very good business,
because I lost all my money.
I lost it all.
It all went out the door.
But I was very--
I didn't want to be a failure.
So I kept trying and
trying and trying and doing
everything I could.
I actually hired my best friend,
Scott, to come work with me
for basically free.
And we just struggled,
and every single day, we
were in that shop trying to
figure out how to make it
in a brick and mortar business.
And then one day, we
were like, why don't we
try to sell our coffee online?
And that's when we
developed Death Wish Coffee.
And it was a recommendation
from our customers,
because they would always
come in, and be like, hey,
can I have-- give me
your strongest coffee.
And we'd go and be
like, all right,
do they want the darkest coffee?
Or do they want the
most caffeinated coffee?
And we were like,
well, wait a minute.
Let's just sit down for a
minute and figure this out.
Let's make a coffee
that's not only dark,
not only tastes strong, but
also has the most caffeine.
And that's what we did.
We developed this
coffee by just blend--
well, through a lot
of experimentation.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well,
let's back up, because I do
think it's important
to qualify Death Wish
Coffee is known online as the
"world's strongest coffee."
MIKE BROWN: Yes.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: How do
you qualify and quantify
what that means to be the
world's strongest coffee?
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, you know, I
was never focused on caffeine
at the outset.
It was always about
taste and flavor.
"Caffeine Informer" and a
few other publications online
deemed us the "world's strongest
coffee" with caffeine levels.
But I don't know.
Personally, I don't like to
focus on that, just because you
can brew coffee stronger
by just adding more coffee
and using less water.
So to me, it was all about
flavor, and good flavor.
And everything
that-- when I drink
a cup of coffee in the
morning, I want to wake up.
I want it to hit my taste buds,
and my eyes just shoot open.
That's what I focused
on, that experience.
But going back to your
question, like I said,
I don't like to focus
on the caffeine.
But the caffeine does have
something to do with it.
And because we use
robusta beans--
robusta beans have
between two and three
times the typical caffeine
content of arabica beans--
we do naturally get more
caffeine in our coffee.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And that's
a big part of it, right?
Because one would
think that it would
be easy to make a new
"world's strongest coffee."
You just go make a coffee, and
then find a bunch of caffeine
and add it.
MIKE BROWN: Get
your caffeine, yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: But that's
not really what's going on.
You guys have brewed
this batch of beans
and roasted it in such a way to
just naturally get this effect
without having to force it.
MIKE BROWN: Right, yeah.
It's organic.
It's fair trade.
There's no additives.
We don't add any caffeine to it.
It's just pure coffee.
And we're purists,
believe it or not.
And we love just straight
black drip coffee.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Sure.
So you find this niche, and
you say, OK, I can start.
People are demanding a
certain thing from me,
the strongest coffee,
high caffeine,
but also really bold flavor.
We got that.
We want to get it
out to the people.
So you left brick and mortar
behind, and just said,
we can do this via the web.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, pretty much.
I still own my coffee
shop right now,
and it's doing
better, thank god.
But yes, we took a stab
at the online market.
Because my customers
were like, hey,
why don't you try
selling this online?
And I was like, all
right, I'll try.
And I sold the bag
via Google Ads.
That's how I sold my first bag.
And I got my first good review.
And the guy was like--
I still remember his
name, Philip [INAUDIBLE]
out of Oakland.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Hi, Phil in Oakland.
It's adorable.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, I
felt out of Oakland.
He bought the first bag, and
he gave me a good review.
He was like, this is some
strong coffee and some
of the best coffee I ever had.
And from there,
that review led up
to another sale
and another sale.
So I was selling basically
one pound a week,
and then two pounds a week,
and then three pounds a week.
And all of a sudden, it just
snowballed into this company
where it was me at first, me and
one of my ex-baristas, Megan.
And then one day, "Good Morning,
America" gave me a call.
They were like, hey, we heard
about your coffee online.
We want to open the
show with it tomorrow.
Can we come up
and interview you?
And I was like, at that moment--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Let me
ponder that for a second.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, you'd think
I would say yes immediately.
But I don't know.
There was that--
I don't know.
For me, it was a brave step,
because I knew I wanted it,
but I didn't know
if I was ready.
But I was just like, yes.
And they came that day.
I'm like, when are
you going to come?
I was thinking a week or two.
They were like, we'll
be there in three hours.
So "Good Morning America" showed
up at my story in three hours.
I closed the store.
I cleaned it up.
And they interviewed me.
And the next morning, they
opened "Good Morning America"
drinking Death Wish
Coffee in our mugs.
And Sam Champion was a
weather man at the time.
And he was their coffee expert.
And he said, this is
some great coffee.
And then from there,
orders took off.
I didn't have enough coffee,
enough bags, enough people.
And that's how I
basically hired everyone.
It was just because it
was just me at the time.
And I was like, oh, my god,
I have all these orders
that I have to fulfill.
Where am I going to find
people to help me do this?
So I went to my customers
in my coffee shop,
and I literally
asked my customers.
Can you help me
fulfill my orders?
And that's where it
started, and that's
where I found the
greatest people.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Great, and which
brings us to a lot of you guys.
And the interesting thing I find
about that is, like you said,
you picked people that
you knew or people
who were customers of yours.
You guys are not necessarily
barista, coffee related.
KANE GROGAN: Teah was.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah.
TEAH TERIELE: Yeah, I knew
nothing about marketing though.
I knew a little bit about
coffee, but I was [INAUDIBLE]..
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So how was the--
KANE GROGAN: We're skipping
a few major, major points.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So fill it in.
What are the major points?
KANE GROGAN: So one of the
things that Mike has omitted
in that rags to riches story is
that he was looking for a way
to supplement some income
because the coffee shop was
failing, and he found a
product that worked out.
And they, him and Megan,
would just reach out
to massive amounts of--
just send e-mails, cold e-mails.
Hey, we have the world's
strongest coffee.
That's how "Good Morning
America" found it.
It was literally in a
basement, and they were just
sending e-mails like,
we have this thing.
It got mentioned in a few
other publications first,
and then when "Good
Morning America" came,
it was way worse than
what Mike just said
when all those orders came in.
And I came on at that point.
Teah came on a little
bit after that.
Our good friend, Eric
Donovan, was there,
who you know him personally.
And there was thousands
and thousands of orders.
And I remember just seeing it.
And we were in
this basement where
the floor is not
really finished,
and it's shorter than I am tall.
And it was just piles,
literal piles, of orders.
And we were stickering bags,
filling coffee, and weighing it
out one bag at a time.
It was insane.
We got kicked off of Amazon.
We got a lifetime
ban off of eBay
because people
thought we were scams.
So that was interesting.
So it took us the--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
What was the scammy--
KANE GROGAN: They
didn't get their bag.
On our website at
the time, which,
if you could go back there--
as I'm sure you guys know,
there's an archive.org
or whatever it
is, where you can see websites.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah,
Google Wayback Machine.
KANE GROGAN: The
Google Wayback Machine?
I wouldn't have bought
it, so that's on them
because they bought
it off that website.
TEAH TERIELE: Comic Sans,
embossed everything.
KANE GROGAN: "World's
Strongest Coffee,"
Las Vegas, flash,
flash, flash, flash.
MIKE BROWN: I was the web
developer of that web site.
It converted like
crazy, first of all.
The conversion rate on there
is better than it is now.
[LAUGHTER]
KANE GROGAN: You'll
get it in five days,
and it's like three, four weeks.
And we thought it
was a dead company.
I didn't get hired for--
I kept coming back every
day for three months,
and I didn't actually
get hired because we
didn't think it was going
to be a company after that.
Well, we just
watched a ship sink,
and let's play the "Titanic"
song as we go down.
And it wasn't that.
We, through customer
service, and just
apologizing to everybody and
saying, you're going to get it,
people kept ordering.
And then we spent the
next year and a half
trying to build a
foundation to the company.
We moved into a warehouse.
We begged and begged and
begged Amazon and eBay
to let us back on.
TEAH TERIELE: And now we're the
best selling coffee on Amazon.
So that worked great.
KANE GROGAN: And I
think on Google too.
And for the internet,
for a lot of times,
we're the number one
coffee, and sometimes,
the number one grocery
product on Amazon.
So that was just a testament
to Mike, and him being like,
we're going to do
this the right way.
We're not going to
screw people over.
We're not going to fold.
We're just going to give
everybody what we promised.
And we were able to deliver,
and it was a pretty amazing time
for the company.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: One of the
common threads of the story
seems to be this foundation
based around communication.
You guys are very,
very communicative.
Like you said, people
were placing an order
expecting it in five days.
You're then reaching out
to them three weeks later
communicating the delays.
But this is not uncommon.
Like you guys embraced
the online space,
you guys embraced so
much social media.
Talk about why going
that route, like
you could easily
have taken out a loan
and spent $100,000 on
a marketing campaign.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
But going this route
seems to have been
very effective for you.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, our number one
value is customer satisfaction.
I give everyone absolute
freedom to go above and beyond
to make sure our customers
are satisfied and happy.
And I know people say that a
lot, especially businesses.
But our number two
value is profitability.
And it's all a ranking system.
So we will, because customer
satisfaction is our number one
value, and then to
be profitable is--
it's two or three or four,
I can't remember exactly--
but we will take losses to
make our customers happy.
So we'll go above and
beyond to do that.
One story I'm thinking of
that just pops into my head
is one day a customer
called, and he
was very upset with our K-Cups.
We had to do K-Cups,
and Keurig came out
with a new brewer,
the Keurig 2.0.
And the guy is like,
I bought your cups.
They don't work
in my new machine.
And he was very upset.
And I'm like--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: You don't
mess with people's coffee.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, exactly.
So I was like, oh, how am I
going to fix this problem?
So I talked to the customer
service, and they were like,
oh, we can send him another bag.
And I'm like, no, let's just
send him a better brewer.
So we went, and we found the
top rated single serve brewer.
And we sent this guy
a brand new brewer.
And it wasn't a Keurig brand.
I think it was the OXX BOXX.
And it was just the top
rated brewer at the time,
and we sent that to him.
And I've never--
and that guy, he
turned out to be a CEO of
some big construction company.
And he was floored.
He was like, you
guys are amazing.
And to me, that's
what I'm saying.
I don't know.
That means a lot about
my customer service team
that they would think
of it, think to do that.
And that's what we're all
about, just making people's day,
being able to provide that
type of value to our customers.
Where it's not just here's
another bag of cups, good luck.
No, we want to really
embrace customer service.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well, it
seems to go more than just
embracing good customer service,
because you've expanded out
into social media
in unique ways that,
again, foster communication
and community.
Which is interesting for a
consumer product company,
I think, and that
sort of leads us
into the conversation
about the podcast.
So as part of all of
this social media growth,
you guys have created your own
identity and branded a podcast.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah.
Dustin could talk a little
bit more about that, I bet.
But I mean, to me, we want
to fuel people's passion.
That's our motto.
And to do that, I feel like we
have to be in contact with them
on a regular basis.
And sometimes people are only
buying coffee once a month.
So we were thinking, how can
we be a part of these people's
lives on an ongoing basis?
And that's where
the podcast came in.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Yeah, when
Michael first brought it up,
to me, it was a way to give
a voice for the company.
Not only with our employees,
so we do employee interviews,
but also with all
the influencers
that we work with
because we worked
with a lot of influencers
that now have a voice
through the company
with the podcast.
But on top of that, it
gives a little bit more
for the customer to be
a part of the company
and also keep really well
informed with the company.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
There's a clear style
to the identity of the company.
Obviously, it's a bold step
to call yourself Death Wish
Coffee.
Why would you want to
actively drink something
that is threatening your life?
But that sort of is--
MIKE BROWN: Do you want to
hear the story behind that?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
I do, absolutely.
MIKE BROWN: So the whole
thought of the name
and the image of
the coffee is when
I was coming up with Death
Wish Coffee, I was sitting.
It was at night.
So imagine me sitting
in a room at night.
It's dark out.
All I have is this computer
screen in front of me.
And I was in my second
floor apartment.
And poor, I was broke as a joke.
I was so poor.
And I'm like, what am I--
I had this product in mind.
And how do I put
this on a screen?
And I looked down at this can.
I was I was drinking a
Four Loko at the time.
All right.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: If that
doesn't say [INAUDIBLE]
work does.
[INAUDIBLE]
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, I was drinking
a Four Loko at the time.
And the koozie I had on it had
a picture of this mean dog.
And my girlfriend
bought me this koozie
when she went away on vacation.
And it said death wish under it.
And I'm like, oh, that's
a pretty cool name.
I could go with that for
a name of this coffee.
And how am I going to--
what would I want to see if I
walked into somebody's kitchen?
Like if I saw a
bag of coffee, what
would I pick up and look
at and be intrigued by?
And I had this image
of a poison bottle,
like an old school poison vial,
where you'd pick up and be
like, what is this?
What kind of coffee
are you drinking
with this poison label on it?
And that was the whole
concept behind it.
And I was like, death wish,
poison bottle, this could work.
So I went into Photoshop and
Photoshopped some stuff around.
And so I got the
preliminary logo.
It's not the logo it is now.
I'm pointing to my
wrist, because I actually
have the logo on my wrist.
KANE GROGAN: It's not real.
MIKE BROWN: It's just
a temporary tattoo.
KANE GROGAN: There
are tattoos though.
We do have tattoos of it.
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, it
was that poison logo.
That's the whole image I
had in my brain at the time.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well, it's
fed so much into the larger
identity at this point.
You guys with the podcasts
have really embraced this.
Dustin, I know
you're big into MMA.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And you
guys have some influences
from that space.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: That
and rock and roll, yeah--
that whole area of
edgy influencers
has just opened up to us.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It
becomes like a lifestyle
brand at a certain point.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Absolutely.
KANE GROGAN: Pretty early on
it became a lifestyle brand.
We realized-- and I don't think
it was the intent-- if you look
at some of our
original ads, it was
a lawyer who can't
wake up in the morning
so he drinks the coffee.
But we found out
that our number one
people that were spreading
the word were either musicians
or recovered addicts
who wanted something
to sink their teeth
into and a brand that
really spoke to them.
And so many people drink coffee.
It's the number two commodity
in the world behind oil.
And we had the edgiest,
most bad ass brand.
And when we started this
thing, or when Mike started,
there was no "world's
strongest coffee."
Now, you can Google--
it's weird that I'm here.
[LAUGHTER]
I get to say that.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: You, you--
KANE GROGAN: Now you can
search on the internet.
No, it's kind of cool.
But you can see so
many different people
claiming to have that claim.
And one of my
favorite stories is
we see so many websites
that try to knock us off.
And there was one that
used our exact HTML code
and didn't take the bottom off.
So it said, why try Death Wish?
Click here.
And our bag.
TEAH TERIELE: Our address.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It was also
effectively signing people up
for your [INAUDIBLE].
KANE GROGAN: That was cool.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Totally.
TEAH TERIELE: Exactly,
yeah, the opt in,
actually, we collected
email addresses
from some imposter's website.
KANE GROGAN: Yeah, they failed.
TEAH TERIELE: It was crazy.
KANE GROGAN: They had our bag
with their logo Photoshopped
on top of it.
And we would email them and
be like, that's our bag.
And they're like, no, it's not.
I'd say it has our address
on it, on the side of it,
the bag that you still
put on your website.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: We
half Photoshopped it.
KANE GROGAN: Yeah,
it was ridiculous.
TEAH TERIELE: But speaking to
it being a lifestyle brand,
there are people who rock
our shirts and our hats
and everything like that
without actually even trying
the coffee.
KANE GROGAN: And get tattoos.
TEAH TERIELE: And get tattoos--
they've probably tried the
coffee at that point, though.
KANE GROGAN: That's true.
I'd hope so.
TEAH TERIELE: Sure, just do it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
You've mentioned tattoos.
Sorry to cut that off.
Were you--
TEAH TERIELE: Oh, yeah, so
a few of our biggest fans
definitely have
our logo tattooed
on them, which is insane.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Is it five?
TEAH TERIELE: People
call us all the time.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Do
five people have them?
TEAH TERIELE: It's
way more than five.
MIKE BROWN: It's way
more than five now.
I'd say it's closer to 20.
TEAH TERIELE: They call
us, and they say, hey,
we want to get
your logo tattooed.
Is that OK?
Well, that's a big
commitment, you know.
We're never like, ah,
just go ahead and do it.
It's kind of like, are you
sure you want to do this?
We do try and kind of talk them
down, but it is pretty cool.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
We're honored.
You guys just finished the
New York City tattoo artist?
KANE GROGAN: Tattoo
artist [INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Did you watch anybody
get a Death Wish tattoo?
TEAH TERIELE: No, actually.
KANE GROGAN: We weren't--
I mean, it's tough.
It's a weird commitment.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Just you.
KANE GROGAN: Yeah, Mike got one.
TEAH TERIELE: Yeah,
but that's temporary.
KANE GROGAN: Yeah, we
always joke after they
get it like, oh, that sucks.
We're actually selling our name.
We're going to be
something else now.
But no, it's insane.
It very early became
a lifestyle brand.
And one of our first marketing
campaigns was, what fuels you?
You're fueled by death.
And to skip forward
back to the podcast,
which started a few months ago--
and Jeff is also the co-host
of that, and he headed
that whole project--
we found out very early
on that it wasn't just
musicians and all these people.
It was engineers.
It was comic book
artists, nurses.
JEFF AYERS: Nurses.
KANE GROGAN: Passionate
people about what
they do for a living--
JEFF AYERS: Astronauts,
your parents--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
--and their art.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Olympians.
JEFF AYERS: Fueled by
death isn't just an idea
of what is your coffee.
And coffee, like we keep
saying, is a lifestyle.
But fueled by death is every
single one of us in this room.
Every single one of us outside
of this room on this planet
wants to do
something significant
before we leave this
planet for good,
because death is
inevitable, whether you
get hit by a bus in five minutes
or you live to be 90 years old.
And what's interesting is
that everybody in the world
enjoys figuring that out,
whether it's a hard journey
to get there, or it's
something that you
know you're passionate about.
And it's very interesting to
attack a conversation that way,
and that's where the idea
of this podcast came about.
And it's interesting to be
able to bring it to a business.
And because we're not
sitting there and being like,
well, what kind of
coffee do you like?
And why does that fuel you?
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: It'd
get boring real quick
JEFF AYERS: What?
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: That
would get boring real quick.
JEFF AYERS: It would
get incredibly boring.
But we've talked to
astronauts and rock
stars and normal people.
And why are you-- what gets
you out of bed in the morning?
Why do you get out of
bed in the morning?
And what gets you out
of bed the next morning?
Why are you doing it?
Not the coffee,
there's something
that you're passionate
about, and that conversation
will never not be interesting.
And that's what we are all
about as a lifestyle brand
too, because what's fun
about a coffee company
is coffee is a lifestyle.
All of you out there
probably have your own way
that you drink coffee, and it
becomes your morning ritual,
whether it's just putting
it in a drip machine
and hitting the brew button--
KANE GROGAN: Or going
to a gas station.
JEFF AYERS: Or going
to a gas station,
or taking out your chemistry
set and really making
that perfect cup of coffee.
Whatever it is,
that is your passion
for your coffee at that moment.
But after you drink your
coffee, then your day starts.
And then what are you
doing with your day?
And we want to be
a part of your day,
not just in that
beginning of it.
KANE GROGAN: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It's a great narrative
to hear about the passion,
the seeking passion
in the people who are around
you and apart of that lifestyle,
and then equating
that back to what
you went through to actually get
this thing up off the ground.
Looking back at
it now, were there
times when you
thought-- you know what?
This isn't worth it.
Or were there times
that you had to re-find
that passion in yourself
of we can make this work?
I do want to do it, even
though it's daunting.
MIKE BROWN: Early on
with the coffee shop,
I believe when I
started Death Wish,
I was probably only one or two
months from closing the doors,
because I just didn't
have any money left.
I had my car repoed.
I had to sell my house.
I had to move back
in with my mom.
I was living behind the garage.
So I was very close
to calling it quits.
But I am super--
I didn't want to be a failure.
That to me, that word--
and it's funny.
I think back, and people,
my friends and family,
they'd be like, hey
Mike, how are things
going at the coffee shop?
And every time like,
ah, they're going great.
Thanks for asking.
But deep inside,
I was just like,
I'm crashing and burning here.
Oh.
So yeah, after that, I'm
like, I got to try something.
So once the online sales
started to pick up,
I'm like, holy crap.
Maybe I can keep this thing
open a little bit longer.
And I'm like, if I just
make $5,000 a year,
that's pretty much all
I need to make things
if I worked a little longer.
So yeah, there was that time
where I was at the absolute
ready to call it quits.
But yeah, I hung on, and
I kept going with it.
And I was just like, I'll pay
my bills back someday, I guess.
And I did, so.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I do want to
speak about something specific,
which is I would like for you
guys to talk about the Super
Bowl ad.
MIKE BROWN: Oh, man.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And
how that came to pass,
because I think it's a
testament to your activity
on the social media space
and how hard you guys
work to build that
community, and then
actually, that community
paying you back interestingly.
JEFF AYERS: We have
the greatest fans,
community, customers in
the world, hands down.
We keep going back to lifestyle.
We keep talking about that.
They made it a lifestyle.
They made this brand what it is.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: And
they're the reason
why we got the Super Bowl
commercial in the first place,
because it was--
it was into, its--
MIKE BROWN: Small
Business Big Game.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: You
don't have a [INAUDIBLE]..
DUSTIN ALEXANDER:
Small business.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: [INAUDIBLE]
TEAH TERIELE: So basically,
Intuit QuickBooks
put out a contest
for a small business
with less than, I
think, 50 employees.
And about 15,000 businesses
actually entered that,
and we were one of them.
And it was a vote-based
contest, so basically, you
would ask your community
to vote for you.
Click a very simple link.
And essentially, the
contest was very simple.
The person with the
most votes would win.
So it ended up being
narrowed down to, I think,
a few hundred, and then
10, and that was insane.
Out of 15,000, we had no idea.
But coming back to the
failure conversation
that you were having, I think
that was the first time where
we said, if we don't win
this, that would suck.
It felt like it
would be a setback,
and it was almost our--
KANE GROGAN: We put so
much work into that.
TEAH TERIELE: We put
so much work into it,
it felt like it would
be the end of the world.
And I think that is one of
the reasons why we ended up
winning.
MIKE BROWN: Because we
put 100% of our focus
on winning the competition.
Which sounds silly,
but it really
brought our team together,
that one driving purpose.
And every day, we'd start.
We'd be like, how are we
going to get more votes today?
How are we going to
get more votes today?
TEAH TERIELE: Yep.
MIKE BROWN: And it came down to
us and Chubbies and Vidler's.
Vidler's, is a five and
dime out of Buffalo, New
York, great small little store.
They had all of Buffalo, all
6 million people in Buffalo
behind them, voting every day.
TEAH TERIELE: They
were a brick and mortar
shop that would sold
the tiny figurines,
and Chinese finger traps.
JEFF AYERS: Little candies
KANE GROGAN: They
didn't even want to win.
They were like, we're not online
but what do we do if we win?
TEAH TERIELE: They were
like, wow, this is amazing.
KANE GROGAN: And Intuit
did tell us after.
I don't know if I
should say this.
But they were like,
if someone like that
won, we wouldn't ever
do this contest again,
because there's no way to
quantify that or help that out.
But it was insane.
In the first three months-- it
was a six month competition--
and the first three months
started with 15,000.
And I honestly didn't
think we had a chance.
We were seven
employees at the time.
We were going against some
juggernauts of companies.
For instance, Chubbies
Shorts, while they
have a little less
than 50 employees,
they have 125 college-brand
ambassadors spreading the word,
which aren't on the books.
Which I think that's cheating.
[LAUGHTER]
That's just my
opinion, no big deal.
MIKE BROWN: Very nice,
those guys are good guys.
JEFF AYERS: They were cool.
They were cool.
MIKE BROWN: We're
friends with them.
KANE GROGAN: But when they
said we were in the top 10,
it became very real.
And then it was like, OK, we did
a lot of work up to this point.
But we were still doing
our day to day stuff.
Once they were like,
you guys are 1 of 10--
and they basically picked.
You had to have a
community of people voting,
but they also picked
really good stories.
Some of the people we were
going against in the top 10
were this Harvard
Business person.
This awesome, awesome
chick was trying
to solve world hunger
by you put your fruit
or whatever on this paper, and
it will make it last longer.
And it's like, we
just sell coffee.
We're going against
amazing, amazing stories
and amazing companies,
and all 10 of them
were very incredible stories.
So when we actually won
it, it was the first time
we came together as a team.
And really, team is the
most important thing.
You can really do
anything you want to do.
You just have
everyone bought in.
And I think we realized
that we can accomplish
pretty much anything,
and it sounds so cliche,
but if you put your mind to it.
And every day, Mike
would be like, what is it
$7 million worth to you?
What would you do
for $7 million,
because that's essentially
what you're getting?
You're getting a $7
million commercial,
and we were going to
be set as a business
if we could just figure
out how to win this thing.
And it was a lot of pressure,
and there were months
where we didn't have a day off.
We were to go into every event.
And me and Mike would go
to a literal football game
and just hand out things
like, we're a coffee company.
Vote for us.
TEAH TERIELE: In
Buffalo, I might add.
KANE GROGAN: In
Buffalo, we didn't
realize we were going
against those guys, but--
Teah knows.
Teah, she's the head
of our marketing.
So she had, OK,
let's try this today.
Let's try this today.
We're not there.
We're not winning.
And it was insane.
TEAH TERIELE: I would say that
if we didn't establish customer
service as our number one value
way before this competition,
I don't think we would have
won because it wouldn't
have resonated with our fans
or with our community at all.
And we have made it a point to
involve them with the company
the entire time.
So I think that kind of sets up.
Our fans would contact
us, and say, hey, I
set a calendar
invite on my calendar
so that I remember to
vote every single day.
KANE GROGAN: Every day.
TEAH TERIELE: I created a
separate mailing list opt in
for people.
We would send one a day, and
almost no one unsubscribed
from that list, which is insane.
And the open rates and the
click rates were incredible.
So our community and
just placing them
on top of our values I think
is the most important thing
that we ever did.
And we never knew it would
have actually come back
to us in such a great way.
KANE GROGAN: Being
real and genuine also,
and one of the things
that Mike and Teah found
out early on where people
wanted to see your faces.
You're now their
favorite coffee brand.
And we made our
brand very relatable.
None of us have experience
in any of the things
we have jobs in now.
Most of us didn't
graduate from college.
We basically Googled
how to run a business.
JEFF AYERS: [INAUDIBLE]
KANE GROGAN: Yeah,
thank you so much.
No, but seriously
it was literally
like we had a Google education.
I know you guys
probably heard that,
and it might be one of
those weird triggers things
like, blech.
But we did.
How do you run social media?
How do you run an ad campaign?
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: And
we still do it today.
KANE GROGAN: We still do that.
And because of that,
we were able to--
we didn't have a whole
20 years of experience,
and this is the way it is.
This is the way
we're going to go.
A lot of those dinosaurs
fall with the times.
We are the times,
like we literally
grew up in this
age and this era,
and we figured out
how to do everything
by just searching it online.
And it's like a testament to
the power of what you guys do,
which is incredible, and why
we are where we are today.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, it is a story
of a very meteoric rise.
A very short time period to
go from the brick and mortar
basement roasting, coming
up with the recipe,
to where you are now, where
the line is diversified.
Like you said, you're making
everything from whole bean
to K-Cups that people can buy
and just pop in a machine.
I want to have you guys
speak to someone out there.
Maybe here, it's a
Googler, or maybe it's
somebody who is watching
the video at home that
has their thing, their
passion, and they want
a similar kind of experience.
What would you tell them?
How would you advise them to
get involved into that, to maybe
not mimic what you
guys have done,
but at least be on that path?
MIKE BROWN: Yeah,
just go for it.
And when you feel like
you're getting uncomfortable,
then just push a little further.
Because I feel like, thinking
back, at that point in my life
where I almost quit, I
was that close to success.
You know what I mean?
I was that close, and I did
just push a little bit further.
So whatever you're doing, if
you have a passion, go for it.
And right when you
get to that point
where you're about to quit,
just be like, actually, no.
I'm going to push myself
two steps further.
And I think if
everyone did that, was
just a little bit
more persistent,
the things you can
accomplish are amazing.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Do you guys agree?
TEAH TERIELE: Yeah.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: You
guys, the podcast creators
who are here, you guys
just started doing it out
of nowhere.
JEFF AYERS: Right, yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
And you guys have now
grown to a fairly
decent presence.
JEFF AYERS: We're
still a baby cast,
just 30 episodes out right now.
But yeah, one thing I
say about this company,
and this really works
towards anything
you're passionate about, is
that this company, Death Wish
Coffee, I always equate it to
a living, breathing organism.
It's something that
learns every day.
It's not just coffee.
It's not just the brand.
It's what we're
trying to achieve,
what we're trying to do.
And anything, whether it's
the video game you like,
or the hobby that you're
creating in your workshop
at home, or the job that
you have to go to day in
and day out, there's
always another journey.
There's always another path you
can take to get to the goal.
The goal is just there, but
that's never the finish line.
There's never a finish line,
and we talk about that a lot
on the podcast.
In fact, one of the
influencers of the company
said it the best.
And we quote him probably
every single time.
And Dustin knows who
I'm going to say.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER:
Yeah, EJ Snyder.
JEFF AYERS: It's EJ Snyder.
He's on "Naked and Afraid."
He said it the best.
He said you either
win or you learn.
There is no losing.
There's never losing.
And when you win,
there's more to go.
And that's a testament
to what we do, but it's
a testament to what you all
do, what anybody can do.
And I think that's powerful.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: And just to
speak on what Michael brought
up, Jeff and I were
podcasting before we started
podcasting before the company.
We had our own
little mini podcast.
But we were kind of
hitting the end of the road
there where it was
like, is this done?
Are we done with this?
And we decided we were
going to hang on to it,
and then that's when
Mike was like, well,
why don't you do
it for the company?
And it was like,
yeah, let's do it.
Let's get it together.
Now we have a vision.
We have a focus, and
now it's been great.
It's been amazing.
It's been an amazing trip, and
it's been very short so far.
JEFF AYERS: And we're
not even started.
We started out doing the idea.
Hey, let's have a
weekly podcast where
people can learn
about the company,
but we can also
ask those questions
to influencers and
interesting people,
and the employees as well.
But now, we're adding video,
and we're adding live video.
We're doing Facebook Live,
and we're doing as we do it.
And live, I'm learning how to do
TV tricks as we're going live.
So I'm on camera talking to you
and also putting camera two on,
as it's happening,
with other graphics.
And I'm failing, but
I'm doing better at it
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
He's learning.
KANE GROGAN: He's learning.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEFF AYERS: So there's
always new ideas.
There's always new ways
to, not even just-- it's
not improving something.
It's just going farther,
going that extra step.
It's awesome.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER:
And it's always
going to be tough when
you're breaking ground.
We're doing things that no other
specialty coffee companies.
No other coffee companies
are making a podcast
like we're doing or making
comic books like we do.
But when you break ground,
nobody's been there before.
You can't just Google it.
How do I start a
podcast and make it
a live show on Facebook Live?
You're not going
to get an answer.
So it's just the nature of
the beast of breaking ground.
You're going to have
to figure out stuff
that nobody's figured
out yet, but that's
where the success comes from.
TEAH TERIELE: Going
back to Mike's story,
I think this is
really important.
Mike mentioned pushing past
your uncomfortable point.
Making a list of your
worst case scenario,
I know that's what
Mike definitely did,
and weighing whether or
not those things are worse
than failing business wise.
I know Mike made a list of
his worst case scenario,
and all of them
ended up happening.
[LAUGHTER]
He moved back into his mom's
place, et cetera, et cetera.
But you do have to push
past that a little bit.
So I do think, going back
to your original question,
make a list of the worst things
that could possibly happen,
and if you're OK with
those things happening
at the expense of creating
an amazing business, yeah,
just try it out.
It won't definitely work,
but at least you'll know.
You'll know what's to come.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Part of
that worst case scenario
is not doing it at all.
KANE GROGAN: That's true.
Part of what we kind of omitted
from this rags to riches story
is Mike had a career.
He had his master's
in accounting,
he was an accountant for the
state, worked for the state.
Had seen all these
people that do this thing
where they show up every day to
work, and they're just like--
No one's really happy.
There's nothing
really driving them.
They're just kind of robotic.
They just get up, and
they drink their coffee,
and then they go to
work and do their thing.
Then they go home,
and they go to bed.
And he's like, I hate this.
I want to do
something that I like.
And I like being
in coffee shops.
I don't know much about coffee,
but I can figure it out.
And then a lot of us were
at crossroads in life
when we joined the
team, and I would
say that the most important
thing is just never settling.
I know that.
So he had a career.
He didn't like it.
He tried something else, and it
took five or six years before.
Everyone told him
it was the worst
decision he was going to make.
I, personally, I dropped out of
community college three times.
I was a banker.
I had the whole
career in banking
when I was in my early 20s.
I hated it.
I quit.
My family and friends told
me it was the worst decision.
I moved back to
upstate New York,
and I ended up basically
homeless for a while.
JEFF AYERS: My couch.
KANE GROGAN: His
couch, Eric's couch--
I spent a lot of time with
Matt and his beautiful wife.
And it was a very, very dark
time, but I found Death Wish,
and I just seized
the opportunity.
I know Teah's got
similar stories.
Alyssa worked for "Teen Vogue,"
I think for a little while.
She still does.
And we've all done things.
You worked for a kitchen.
It was a lot of different
times where we just
weren't happy with our current
situation, and a lot of people
settle.
And I think that's the
biggest mistake you can make.
And just dealing with it,
because you think that's all
you got.
Just looking for opportunities,
and when they're there,
doors will open.
You just have to know
to walk through them.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Very good, very good.
I do want to leave plenty
of time for you guys
to ask questions as well.
There are microphones
in the aisles,
so I encourage you to make
your way to the microphones
with your questions prepared.
While people are
getting ready, I
want you guys to
go down the line,
and I want you to tell me
how you take your coffee.
MIKE BROWN: Yes, I take
my coffee out of a Chemex,
typically black,
no sugar, no cream,
strong as you can make it.
But I only drink
it in the morning.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: I get
a little weirder with it.
I make something
called Death Proof
Coffee, which is mixed with
butter, MCT oil, blended.
I stick a few other
things in there.
But yeah, that's
my morning ritual.
One cup in the morning,
I'm good to go all day.
TEAH TERIELE: Typically--
I actually came in
as a coffee connoisseur.
And I was such a brat.
I still love that third wave
coffee, but typically black.
But you'll catch me
going to the Keurig
a lot more than I'll admit.
So here I am.
KANE GROGAN: I have my
two different kinds,
where I have my
hangover on Sunday
where I just like really
just terrible diner
coffee with a bunch
of cream and sugar.
I've also figured out
through this job--
I didn't know much
about coffee--
ways to use it as
a literal utility
to get you through your day.
A lot of people will drink
an energy drink or something
like that.
And Teah would
always be like, dude,
there's more caffeine in
coffee than there is in that.
You don't need that.
It's terrible for you.
So I usually have three
cups between 8:00 and 11:00,
and it'll get me till about
3:00, where I start that crash.
And then I'll have one
more cup, because it
allows me to go home and
get stuff done after work.
JEFF AYERS: I used to be
cream and sugar all the time,
and then I got really
lazy in college.
So it's black, and it's a lot.
I drink probably--
KANE GROGAN: He drinks a lot.
JEFF AYERS: --five
or six cups a day.
My desk is directly next to
all of our coffee machines,
and I'm bouncing off
the walls by 5:00.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: And
he never shuts up.
KANE GROGAN: He never
shuts up, and he
started having panic attacks.
So he's had to calm down.
[LAUGHTER]
Have you ever seen
that Dave Grohl video
where it's like, fresh pots.
His wife was like,
are you all right?
What happened?
It's where he was like--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: That's
maybe not a shining endorsement.
[LAUGHTER]
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: It's
just an occupational hazard
when you work with coffee.
JEFF AYERS: It's
just how it works.
KANE GROGAN: Especially
when you don't
pay for it where we work, and
we have really strong coffee.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER:
[INAUDIBLE] stages.
KANE GROGAN: But
one of the things
I do want to say real
quick is we always
look for alternative
methods, and we just
released a nitro
cold brew, which
is very concentrated
Death Wish coffee.
And Jeff would get home
and have a panic attack
and not know why.
And it's because he
would have one of those
too late in the afternoons.
JEFF AYERS: Three of those.
[LAUGHTER]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
How about you?
ALYSSA HARDY: I wake
up very, very early,
so I start with the Chemex.
And I put a little bit
of almond milk in it.
And then I get to
work, and I make
one the second I get to work
in french press typically.
AUDIENCE: I feel like
we haven't heard a lot
about the coffee itself yet.
So I'm very curious about
things like sourcing,
roasting, how you blend it.
And also, I guess
most importantly,
it's very unusual to have a good
higher end coffee bean made out
of robusta, and what it's like
using that rather than arabica,
which every other single
company I'm aware of uses.
KANE GROGAN: We use
arabica as well.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it's
art pf of the blend.
KANE GROGAN: I think Mike's--
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, our
roasters not here today.
That's probably why we
haven't talked about it much.
JEFF AYERS: If we told
you, we'd have to kill you.
KANE GROGAN: We're going
to kill you anyway.
MIKE BROWN: It's an
Indian Peruvian blend.
So we get the robusta
beans from India.
They're organic and fair trade.
We're actually one of the
few companies out there
that have an organic
source for robusta.
Most robusta you find,
it doesn't have the USDA
organic certification on it.
But we have a very
good supplier.
We work with importers, actually
in New York here and New Jersey
and on the West
Coast, and they're
able to source that for us.
The Peruvian is also
organic fair trade.
Our coffee is
blended post-roast,
so we don't blend the
beans and then roast them.
We roast them separately.
So you'll see, if you
actually open a bag,
you'll see two different
shades in there because we
found that if you
blend it post-roast,
you'll get a fuller flavor.
We use Loring roasters.
It's almost like a giant
popcorn popper I like to say.
There's no direct
flame on the beans
ever, so there's no scorching.
If you crack our beans
open, they're roasted
uniformly straight through.
It's the most efficient
roaster on the market
right now because it
circulates the hot air,
so we don't waste a lot of gas.
There's not a lot
of exhaust either.
It also provides
the benefit of us
not having to have
an afterburner, which
a lot of companies will
have, which will reduce
the environmental impact.
So it's the most environmentally
friendly roaster.
We have two of those.
We have a 35 kilo and
a 70 kilo at this time.
TEAH TERIELE: I want to speak a
little bit on especially coffee
and robusta a little bit.
Definitely when we first
entered the coffee industry,
robusta was not highly regarded.
I wouldn't say it's
highly regarded still.
KANE GROGAN: It's
still not, yeah.
TEAH TERIELE: But the SCAA,
which is the Specialty Coffee
Association of
America, they actually
have set up something
at all of their events
to compete with robusta,
and that's something
that I'm actually really
proud of at this point.
It's cool you get to taste
robusta against each other.
So even though it's not
necessarily like the third wave
light roast choice, it
definitely is its own beast
that people do love and enjoy.
And I think it's 60%
of coffee enjoyed
is a lot of times
mixed with robusta.
MIKE BROWN: Right now, yeah,
especially because there's been
a problem with coffee rust.
And because of this,
the coffee industry
is starting to
make hybrid plants
with arabica and robusta,
because robusta is much more
hardy.
TEAH TERIELE: Supposedly.
MIKE BROWN: It can defend
against this coffee rust
that they were initially
thinking was going
to really raise coffee prices.
But because they're able to
blend the two plants together,
it's resistant.
So actually, a lot of coffee
you're probably getting now
that you thinks arabica
probably has some robusta in it.
JEFF AYERS: There
actually are studies
that were just done where
scientists just cracked
the genome on robusta coffee.
And arabica has been out
there for about a year,
and so both genomes are
now completely mappable.
And that's why we're getting
a lot of these hybrid plants,
which is very interesting,
because now we're
going to be able to
get a new type of bean
that the world's never seen.
And the possibilities of
coffee are endless again.
So it's pretty exciting.
ALYSSA HARDY: I think
a lot of people just--
you hear like, oh, single
origin arabica beans, you just
hear that from different people.
And you think, oh, yeah,
that's the best one, right?
That's what I thought.
I was like, yeah,
that's the best.
You don't know.
You just don't know
until you try it.
So a lot of people just
haven't even tasted it.
TEAH TERIELE: The blind
taste tests are very funny.
Especially coming from me, I
would criticize everyone's way
of brewing coffee,
and I was that person
until someone stuck a blind
taste test in front of me.
And then who was the jerk?
It was me.
KANE GROGAN: Yeah,
but the good thing--
MIKE BROWN: All
personal preference,
all personal preference, I
tell people that all the time.
KANE GROGAN: We try to--
we're like the
gateway coffee drug.
And I think having someone
like Teah that has really
been around coffee
for a long time,
people will buy it because
it has a gimmicky approach.
It's a skull and crossbones,
"world's strongest coffee."
People are like, screw that.
That's stupid.
The third wave coffee people
really didn't respect that.
But the modern person
and most people
don't have that palette yet.
They don't know
what good coffee is.
So we have this thing
where-- you know,
Mike worked at a coffee shop.
He was able to test every
kind of coffee he wanted.
Strong coffee, but he also
wanted it to taste good.
And we charge a
premium price for it.
It is a premium blend.
And we always try to educate.
And Alyssa is an amazing writer,
and she writes a lot of blogs.
And Teah kind of
started that where
we educate our
customers who might
be Dunkin' Donuts, or
Folgers, or the Starbucks,
whatever is convenient.
And then we show them.
This is good coffee, and
here's how you can brew it.
Here's Chemex.
Here's French press.
Here's alternative ways
to enjoy your coffee.
And now, a lot of our
fans that never ever
would have gotten into
that, you see them
with a whole station
set up and their kettles
and they're doing that.
So awesome question, but yeah,
we try to blend the two worlds.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Who else?
I think we have
another question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
You alluded to it earlier.
When you started selling
online, all of a sudden,
there were a lot of
orders coming in,
and you were falling behind.
I was wondering if you could
go a little bit further
into how you scaled
during that process
in terms of vendors,
sources, and also staff.
How quickly did that
scale up and get you
back to where you needed to be?
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, I was
very green back then,
and I was using, I
think, ShipStation--
no, I was using PayPal.
I had to print out
every single order,
and basically, I was
throwing the fire.
You know what I mean?
Throwing the fire when "Good
Morning America" happened
where we had to produce
thousands of pounds of orders
all at once.
And I didn't know how to do it.
And I was operating at a level
where I could probably do maybe
50 pounds a day comfortably.
So how quickly did that happen?
Two months, two
months, we starting
working with ShipStation.
We were bulk printing
orders after that.
We bought another
computer so it wasn't just
one guy printing out the orders.
Kane came on probably
three weeks into it.
KANE GROGAN: Right
around the time.
MIKE BROWN: Teah came along
a little bit afterwards.
And there was five of us.
KANE GROGAN: There was five.
MIKE BROWN: And at the time--
KANE GROGAN: This was
2013, just to give you
some reference of time.
Mike had the idea in 2011.
2012 we started selling.
In March of 2013, "Good
Morning America" happened.
And as I said before, none
of us really had jobs.
We didn't know if it was going
to be a sustainable company.
Around June, after we got
through that whole thing,
and we realized that the
sales were still coming,
and maybe we're on
to something here,
we spent the next year making
sure that what had happened
would never happen again.
So we had flown up
to the roof, but we
didn't have a foundation yet.
So Mike was like, OK, let's
outsource all the stuff
that we can't or don't
want to do in-house.
And then let's start
slowly after that.
Start taking it back in.
So we immediately
made lists on paper.
OK, this is what
we're doing now.
This is the process right now.
How do we either get
rid of the process,
have someone else do it, or how
can we do it more efficiently?
And so one of the
things was, OK,
we can outsource to a
distribution center.
So we went around.
And Teah and Eric,
who's not here,
went around and just interviewed
distribution centers.
And that was a huge thing.
Now we don't have to
actually package coffee.
At that time, I spent anywhere
between 8 to 12 hours a day
packaging coffee.
And then once we figured out
how to make it sustainable,
we started taking
all that stuff back.
And we're still
taking stuff back
to be able to do
everything in-house.
But it was a process.
TEAH TERIELE: Scaling is
probably one of the tougher
things that we've done.
Mike was doing our
accounting for years.
I'm pretty sure he still
has his hands in it.
And I'm the same way with
posting on Instagram.
I shouldn't be
doing that anymore,
but we're all kind of doing it.
Hiring, we did use some temp
services in the beginning,
and we ended up keeping
a few of those people on.
But yeah, scaling is impossible.
It's not like you can look
that up on the internet.
JEFF AYERS: We're still scaling.
KANE GROGAN: I think
the coolest thing is
being able to attract talent.
That's what I was
most excited about.
It took a long time,
because at first, we
would put a Craigslist ad
up, like we know this person.
We're looking for this, but we
don't have money to pay you,
so here's a small money.
But it's like, it
might be bigger later.
And I think the
most exciting thing
for us right now is where we've
done multi millions of dollars
in sales, and
we're still growing
and growing and growing.
Being able to bring
on a Dustin, who
is an absolute beast
in everything he does,
and like, OK, here's a problem.
Figure it out.
So he builds our entire
warehouse inventory.
And then Jeff, you know
so much about broadcasting
and all this, and your voice.
Alyssa, you're a content writer.
Do you want to come over
here and work for us?
And we've been able to do that,
and we're still doing that--
super exciting.
ALYSSA HARDY: Yeah, it's like
working for a small business.
Like I'm somebody that went
from working in a corporation,
and then was very
attracted to this.
What is this small business that
seems to be doing really well?
What's going on over here?
How can I get my
hands into that?
And I think that
as far as scaling
with people, as people
start to see that
and as we had jobs start
opening, people were like,
wait, how can I get
involved in something
that's cool and small
and different than what
working at the state?
We're in upstate New York,
so that kind of thing.
JEFF AYERS: And I don't think
we've even touched on this.
At that point, "Good
Morning America"
you said it was a team 5.
And then that blew up,
and obviously, scaling up.
And like I said, we're
still scaling up.
We have the largest
employee base right now,
and we're at 25?
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: 23.
JEFF AYERS: 23, and
that's the company.
So doing what we do, it's still
how do we maintain that base,
but reach that ceiling
and not go nuts doing it?
So it's a journey.
It really is.
KANE GROGAN: I think
the coolest think also
is being able to do what
we're passionate about.
Matt, when we were having lunch,
he alluded to the 20% time,
and people being
able to have time
to do projects they're
passionate about.
And we're obviously on
a much smaller scale,
but we have a lot of things.
Like for instance,
Alyssa, you might
want to talk about the
Grind It Out campaign,
our first real
marketing campaign where
they had these ideas.
I'll let you talk a
little more about that.
ALYSSA HARDY:
Yeah, so basically,
like we were talking
about our fan base,
we have a lot of
nurses and firefighters
and things like that that really
use the coffee to get them
through the day.
So what we decided to do was
put together a content campaign
where we highlighted
those people, because we
felt like so many companies are
highlighting that cool athlete,
or highlighting this
super famous person.
But who we want to
champion is the people
that are drinking our coffee.
And that might be
the nurse that's
in the hospital or the EMT
or all of those people.
So basically, it was something
where the marketing team, me,
Teah, and our art director,
Thomas, were like, yeah,
wouldn't it be really
cool to put together
some videos of these people,
and blogs, and playlists,
and all this kind of stuff?
And Mike was like, do it.
So it's been able to
give us the freedom
to just make creative
projects and things like that.
JEFF AYERS: We wanted to
showcase the greatest tagline
that you guys came up with.
We want to showcase
how our coffee lives.
And it's not just about whose
hands we can put coffee into,
it's about, like we said, it's
like you get up every morning.
And you might have
a cup of coffee,
and then you're going
to go do something.
Awesome.
Usually, and it's
like, OK, let's
see you do that awesome thing,
and why are you doing that?
And that's where that whole
marketing idea came from.
KANE GROGAN: Grind
it out, hashtag.
ALYSSA HARDY: Yeah,
it's #grinditout.
KANE GROGAN: #grinditout.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER:
Yeah, grind it out.
KANE GROGAN: Everyone
can [INAUDIBLE] for after
[INAUDIBLE]
ALYSSA HARDY: Yeah,
it's like we want
to see everybody's grind,
because like you said,
it's how our coffee lives.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It really
is a powerful and amazing story
of the passion for
a product leading
to the creation of
a family, leading
to the creation of a community.
And it's interesting
that the product itself
is sort of secondary to
all of that for you guys,
that really, it's
about you being
able to work together,
follow your passions,
and continue to grow
this community out there.
To that respect,
please let people know
how they can find all of this.
Where do you go to
hear the podcast?
Where can you check
out the coffee?
MIKE BROWN: Yeah, go
to deathwishcoffee.com.
That's the easiest place.
That's our content
hub for everything.
You can find us on Twitter,
Instagram, and Facebook,
obviously, under
Death Wish Coffee.
The podcast lives right
off our home page.
So go to
deathwishcoffee.com/deathcast.
We're the top selling
coffee on Amazon.
So if you go over there
and type in "coffee,"
we should be under the
headline Best Seller.
You can buy it there,
or you can also get it
on Jet.com and Walmart.com.
KANE GROGAN: But if you
get it on our web site,
we actually have a--
we're going to be in your
guys' employee discounts.
I think in the next quarter.
I worked a deal out with--
I forget who was
the head of that.
But if you do use
discount Google,
you will get 20% off
whatever is on the website.
So you can share
that internally.
It hasn't been
announced yet, but that
should be coming very soon.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It's been announced now.
[LAUGHTER]
KANE GROGAN: Was I not
supposed to say that?
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: You'll be able
to find it on the first day.
KANE GROGAN: He
said he was going
to share it around the office,
and it wasn't a big deal.
It just hasn't been
in the newsletter yet,
so I don't think
I broke any rules.
But surprise!
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: We'll see.
TEAH TERIELE: Also,
get off that newsletter
and get on our newsletter.
JEFF AYERS: Yeah.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER:
And just to touch
on the podcast location,
any Podbean, iTunes,
it's everywhere.
JEFF AYERS: Stitcher, Google
Music, we're up there too.
So you can pretty
much find us anywhere.
And like I said, we're
getting into video too.
So YouTube, we're all over that.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Facebook Live.
JEFF AYERS: All
over Facebook Live.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Excellent.
Well, thank you guys
for taking the time
to come and join us and share
your amazing story with us.
TEAH TERIELE: Thank you.
MIKE BROWN: Thanks
for having us.
ALYSSA HARDY: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Thanks, guys.
DUSTIN ALEXANDER: Thanks.
KANE GROGAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]